okay let's get into audience questions
for the week
many of them related to the really
tragedies that we observed in the united
states over the last week and a half
first question
david we have the biggest military and
most
militarized police in the world why
couldn't the capitol police keep
rioters out what the hell happened and
this is a question that became
an important one very quickly uh
after we as we were witnessing the
events of january 6 the riotous
insurrection fomented by president
donald trump and it is true
the government spends hundreds of
billions on defense
on the military department of the
defense pentagon
department of homeland security on and
on and on
how is it possible that you ended up
with a situation where a mob
breaches the capital the vice president
and members of congress
are are there secret service and
other evacuations and and the within
minutes this mob
i mean we were watching it and it wasn't
very long after the debate started into
the objections over arizona
that the mob had overrun the building
and people needed to take shelter and on
and on so there are two
big picture answers and we'll dig into
each of them
one big picture answer is they didn't
understand the scope of the threat
the other big picture answer is they
understood the scope of the threat and
chose not to be more prepared and
there's a sort of
more benign uh at least as motives go
explanation for that and the more
conspiratorial ones so
let's start with the most conspiratorial
because i'm not going to spend a lot of
time of it
absent evidence and the conspiratorial
version would be
everybody knew exactly what was going to
happen and the reason police weren't
prepared
is because police slash whoever is in
power
were in on a plan to allow this to
happen for whatever reason to make
someone look good or make someone look
bad or to suggest
a pretext for trump to declare martial
law that's the conspiratorial
conspiratorial one police were in on it
and
so far i've not seen evidence of that um
don't attribute malice when incompetence
adequately covers what we've seen
so then we get to the capitol police
didn't know what to expect
versus they knew what to expect and just
didn't
didn't prepare enough there are reports
about the capitol police rejecting
some federal offers for help both in
advance of and in the moment of what was
going on
it still has to be investigated and if
it's true
that capitol police rejected further
offers of help
then that's a disaster and it has to be
investigated
why did leadership refuse the help what
are the explanations and that needs to
be looked at
and then the other side of it would be
they simply didn't realize the risk that
was posed
and they were caught unprepared and that
also requires an investigation because
we're talking about
securing the capital when the vice
president is going to be there
at a time crucial to american democracy
so either way it would be a failure we
just have to
have to figure it out now from a very
you know logistical rote
perspective um a lot of this has to do
with lack of enough perimeters
and you know there's just crowd control
stuff like i don't know if people are
looking for an answer that's very
specific to crowd control but
when you have such a large crowd
it has to be managed earlier it is true
that trump hesitated and ultimately it
seems he was even mike pence who sent
the national guard
once things were going on it is true
that it took a while for
state troopers from virginia and others
show up to show up that's all true
but the reality is it's already too late
at that point uh to try to retake
control of a scene when it has already
degenerated to what it had degenerated
at that point in time
by 1 40 1 50 p.m eastern time on
wednesday it's too late
uh large crowds of protesters have to be
managed earlier
the capital should have been surrounded
and secured earlier
with multiple perimeters and in addition
to that
the crowds should have been directed
even when they were blocks away they
should have been redirected
and that that's the only way you can
manage and direct the crowd that
large because it didn't happen the
protesters
were able to start congregating in large
groups
already close to the capital and then
you had another failure which was as we
saw the barriers breached
still you know kind of far from the
capital
at that point the number of officers
left on the capital steps was too small
to control what was happening and so
the perimeter was pushed further back so
some of the analyses we've seen are that
it was completely unthinkable
not to have multiple layers of police
cordons on the outskirts of the complex
and
even further out fences and barricades
there were some but they're useless
unless you're properly directing the
crowd
you have to start making arrests early
very importantly understand that
when the first people started battling
with the officers at the barriers
near the capitol yes there weren't
nearly enough officers and yes they
never should have been that close in
groups that large
but nobody got arrested and you could
say well the police were overwhelmed how
can they start arresting people right
away it's fair it was all completely
mismanaged but one of the things you
want to do is
you need to start making the arrest
early you need to immediately target the
people that seem most violent
some of the people that were earliest
most violent on video
they stuck around for hours and
eventually made it into the capital so
everything everything that happened was
was done wrong by the way
i'm speaking in defense of the officers
in the sense that early there were
people already being violent with the
officers hitting them
with the barriers themselves the people
being violent with officers
need to be arrested right away and and
they weren't so
everything went wrong the motives and
explanations we still don't know but
from a logistical crowd control
standpoint
everything went wrong in the sense that
none of the stuff that should have been
done was done and
we'll learn more about it i'm sure in
two months when some report is published
that
nobody will see but we'll pay attention
for and we'll take a look at
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience 20
off lucy is a company founded by cal
tech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be
and nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful lucy offers a nicotine gum
in three flavors wintergreen cinnamon
and pomegranate
they also have lozenges which come in
cherry ice flavor
lucy is affordable it'll ship right to
your door you don't have to go out to
the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020. it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent reviews online from
countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.com i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical